احنا النهارده جايين نتكلم على موضوع
اعتقد ان كلنا جربناه في حياتنا مره على
الاقل وهو السياحه ان انا اسافر من حته
لحته
بس احنا هنتكلم على نوع محدد من السياحه
السياحه البيئيه ودورها في
تنميه المجتمعات المحليه هي السياحه فعلا
ممكن تنمي مجتمع محلي هو ده اللي احنا
عايزين نقش النهارده
بس قبل ما ندخل في السكه دي
خلينا نعرف الاول يعني ايه كلمه سياحه
اصلا
المعجم بيقول السفر من بلد الى اخرى
بغرض التنزه
والاستمتاع والترفيه وحب الاستطلاع
المعجم بيقول كده
بس ده كان زمان
ده الاصل بتاع السياحه النهارده السياحه
بقى لها اغراض اخرى يعني هو برده نفس
البدايه في التعريف الانتقال من بلد الى
اخر بس الغرض هنا ابتدا يتطور
فعشان كده ظهرت انواع من السياحه وبقى في
بلاد متخصصه في بعض الانواع من السياحه
طيب عرفنا انواع السياحه
ايه اهميه السياحه
ليه ليه الناس يعني ايه الهدف من ان انا
انمي سياحه في اي بلد
الجواب له شقين
ايه اهميه السياحه للبلد
وايه اهميه السياحه لي كفرد انا البني ادم
او المجتمع المحلي
وعلى فكره الاهميه هنا غير الاهميه هنا
بمعنى
بالنسبه للدوله او البلد
ايه اكثر مشكله عندنا في مصر دلوقتي
بالضبط السياحه هي اكبر مورد للناقض
الاجنبي للدول
انا عايز دولار يبقى اشتغل سياحه بس دي
السياحه الخارجيه اللي هي جايه لي من بره
طيب السياحه الداخليه اللي هو انا اسافر
اروح دمياط اللي في دمياط يروح الساحل
اللي في الساحل يروح النوبه السياحه
الداخليه
السياحه الداخليه عشان كده مهم مش عشان
العمله
استثمارات انا كدوله لازم اجيب فلوس من
بره يجوا يستثمروا عندي ايه الطف مجال
للاستثمارات الخارجيه للسياحه ابني فندق
اعمل شاطئ اعمل مدينه ملاهي اعمل حاجه في
الاثار
جذب الاستثمارات مهمه الدوله فبالتالي
السياحه مهمه للدوله طب الدوله بتعمل كل
الكلام ده ليه
دي اهم نقطه
ايجاد فرص عمل
انا كل دوري كدوله ان انا اوجد فرص عمل
للمواطنين
فبالتالي السياحه من اكبر الموارد لايجاد
فرص عمل اي احد ممكن يشتغل بالسياحه
وطبعا الدوله برده بتبص على موضوع تبادل
الثقافه والحضارات ودي شيء مهم بالنسبه
للدوله عشان تركت نفسها
طب بالنسبه للفرد وهو ده احنا جايين
النهارده عشان كده انا عايز اعرف السياحه
دي مهمه ليه انا في
زمان كانت السياحه مصدر اقتصادي انا بيدخل
لي فلوس من السياحه لما الناس تيجي تزور
المنطقه بيصرفه فبالتالي الدخل بيتوزع في
المنطقه
بس الوضع النهارده اتغير
بقى في مستثمرين سياحيين بيجوا يصرفوا
الفلوس يبني فندق الساعه بيدخل الفندق ما
بيخرجش منه
ما بيصرفش بره الفلوس كلها رايحه للمستثمر
او للفندق او للتورغ شركه السياحه اللي
جايبه الراجل من بره انما المجتمع المحلي
ما استفادش حاجه
فبالتالي بقى المجتمع المحلي بيبص للسياحه
انا مش عايز
ما انا مش طالع منها حاجه
هي زحمه وخلاص
هنا بقى يجي دور السياحه البيئيه
ليه
تعريفات السياحه البيئيه كثيره قوي ومش
هابع دماغكم بكل الدوشه والدش اللي مكتوب
ده كله
حاولنا ان احنا نبسط الكلام ده
مين هنا مهندسين
قليلين قوي
انا عايز الحاجات دي تتحقق عشان يبعث لك
يا حبيبي
عايز مكان طبيعي
مكان الطبيعه في حلوه مميز
عايز مجتمع محل
ساكن جنب المكان الطبيعي ده او في المكان
الطبيعي ده
عايز المجتمع المحلي ده يبقى له تراث يعني
تراث يبقى له تاريخ يبقى له عادات وتقاليد
يبقى له طبخ يبقى له موسيقى يبقى له رسمي
يبقى له
ازياء مميزه
تمام يبقى انا عايز مكان طبيعي سكان
محليين تراس وعايز بقى اللاعيب بقى
المستشفى
اللي يدخل يربط المنظومه دي كلها في بعضها
ويحول المكان لمكان سياحي
المعادله دي بتقول ايه اي مكان في العالم
ممكن يبقى مكان سياحي
انا هنا ما ذكرتش اثار
ونعمل
انا ممكن هنا في دمياط اعمل سياحه بيئيه
لو في مكان طبيعي ما اعرفش عندكم ولا لا
لو في سكان محليين عندهم تراث قوي هل
عندكم ولا لا
لازم تفكري في الحاجه دي
ولو عندي احد ولانك ان هو يتعب ويدخل
بمجهود عشان يعمل
المنتج بتاع السياحه لو اجتمعت الحاجات دي
هاعمل سياحه بيئيه في دمياط او في راس
البر او في دمياط الجديده
طيب الحاجات دي موجوده في مصر
يعني في ناس عملوا الشغل ده في مصر
لازم اعرف لو في ناس عملت الشغل ده في مصر
طب هي مصر اصلا صالحه للسياحه
طول عمرنا مصر بيتقال عليها ايه
اثار اثار اثار بتاعه الاثار اشطر حاجه
عندهم الاثار الفراعنه
طب هل انا عندي مقومات ان انا اعمل سياحه
بيئيه
خلينا نشوف نرجع للمعادله بتاعتنا مكان
طبيعي مميز اللي هي مقاومه الطبيعيه وايه
ثاني سكان محللين وتراس نبدا بالطبيعه
انا عندي مناطق تراث عالمي تبع اليونيسكو
اليونسكو هي اللي بتحميها زي منطقه وادي
الحيتان زي منطقه
جبال النوبه انا عندي مناطق طبيعيه في كل
حته في مصر عندي صحراء في الغرب عندي جبال
في الشارع عندي جبال في سيناء عندي نهر
النيل عندي بحر المتوسط عندي البحر الاحمر
كل ده اماكن طبيعيه
بس في اماكن معينه
ما حدش بيروحها
انا عندي اهم حاجه في المقاومات الطبيعيه
اهم حاجه في العالم في المقاومات الطبيعيه
درجه الحراره
اوروبا في الشتاء بيهربوا
للمنطقه بتاعتنا عشان عندهم جليد وتلج نفس
الحكايه بتحصل في امريكا
نفس الحكايه بتحصل في الجنوب
فبالتالي انا مميز بس مش مصر لوحدها
المنطقه بتاعه الشرق الاوسط مميزه بانتظام
درجات الحراره حنينه فيها فبالتالي انا مش
محتاج اصرف بقى فلوس كتير قوي عشان
التدفئه
مثلا زي ما هيحصل عندهم في اوروبا ربنا
يكون في عونهم الشتاء ده
طيب
امثله مقاومات طبيعيه ده ايه
وادي الحيتان
بحر الرمال الاعظم في الصحراء الغربيه تقف
360 درجه رمله بس
جبال سيناء
بحيره ناصر
واحد سيوه
كهف الجاره في الصحراء الغربيه
النسر الاقرع
في جنوب مصر دي فين
بلطيم
الكثبان الرمليه اللي جنب مالتي المنطقه
دي رائعه من وراء الخيال
جبل علبه عند حلايب وشلاتين
شايفين البيوت ازاي هناك
طيب عندنا مقاومه الطبيعيه
للسكان المحليين موجود طب ازاي امثله مصر
حضانه كم سنه
الفراعنه موجودين من سنه كام
3200 قبل الميلاد
ارجعوا لجوجل احنا بعد الميلاد بكم سنه
2000 الفين
خمسه خمسه مترين هما لسه
في حضارتين قبل الفراعنه
في حضانه بدارك
وحضرتني ادم
ناس بتتكلمش عنهم
وسايبين اثار على فكره
حضانه عشان كده احنا حضانه 7000 سنه
بس على فكره مصر فيها حاجات من قبل 7000
سنه
حد يعرف ايه ده
دي كهوف على الحدود ما بيننا وما بين
ليبيا في منطقه اسمها الجلف الكبير
الكهوف دي فيها رسومات بتسميها رسومات ما
قبل التاريخ
الرسمه دي عمرها حوالي 12000 سنه
ده في الصحراء على الحدود في وسط بحر
الرمله
التشكيل ده موجود في سيناء جنوب سيناء
اسمه النواميس
اتاخر ب 10,000 سنه
الفراعنه موجودين من 5000 سنه
بتاعتهم ده كان عنده 5000 سنه
بعد كده جم بقى حبايبنا المصريين القدماء
ما بين الرسمه دي
والهرم ده
حوالي
امزيجي اللي هم اهلنا في سيوه بيتكلموا
لغه الامازيجيه مختلفه خالص عن العربي
ملهاش علاقه بالعربي
نوبي
نوبي ما لوش علاقه بالعربي خالص
اهل العبابده والبشريه اللي شفناهم شويه
عندهم لغه بتاعتهم اسمها روتانا ولو رحت
عند العبابده والبشريه في حلايب وشلاتين
وكلمتهم عربي
وعندي لغه قديمه قوي هي بواقي اللغه
المصريه القديمه اسمها اللغه القبطيه
بيتم التحدث بها في بعض الكنائس المصريه
لغايه النهارده وعلى فكره اللغه العاميه
بتاعتنا فيها مفردات كثير من اللغه
القبطيه
عندي خمسه
كل ده ثقافه كل ده تاريخ تراث
هل في تطبيقات ناجحه في السياحه البيئيه
عايز اقول لكم ان في ناس اشتغلوا في
الموضوع ده من 35 سنه
يعني قبل ما كلمه سياحه بقيت توجد في
العالم
حد يعرف المهندس شريف الغمراوي
ساكن في المعادي في القاهره
عيلته مرتاحه جدا
خارج المدرسه الالماني
بعد ما خرج من الهندسه لقى نفسه مش
متعاقلم مع القاهره فقرر يسافر جنوب سينا
كنا ساعتها لسه مستعدين جنوب سيناء من
اسعدنا طابا
شريف لها شاطئ هناك حلو قوي فقرر ان هو
يقعد هناك وانا مش راجع القاهره وحاول ان
هو يشتري حته ارض
لو هتعمل ايه يا شريف انا هاعمل عشه واللي
عايز يجي يقعد عندي اهلا وسهلا يقعد في
العشه
ده كان المنظر
سنه 86
اصحاب كثير في المانيا ابتدوا وخريجين
المدرسه الالماني
افواج بتروح عند شريف تقعد تستمتع ببساطه
المكان فراح مسمي المكان ايه بساطه
الناس بتروح تستمتع بالبصل
مع الوقت شريف كتر العشش بقى في ناس كتير
بتيجي فبقى في عشش على فكره كان لوحده ما
كانش فيه اي حد حواليه
طيب
ماريا واحده من الناس اللي كانوا بيجوا
يزوروا في ببساطه حبوا بعض اتجوزوا
حصلت مشكله
خلفه
هيودي بنته فين
مدرسه
ما فيش مدرسه
طب خلاص بسيطه
حبني عشره واعملها مدرسه
وهاجيب مدرسين من القاهره اكل شارب نائم
واخذ مرتب ويعلمني البنت بس البنت هتتعلم
لوحدها
يا بدو يا اللي ساكنين حواليا طبعا شريف
علاقته بالبادو كانت ممتازه عايش
هاتوا لي بناتكم لا احنا ما بنعلمش البنات
يا اخواننا هاتوا لي بناتكم انا هاعلمكم
مع بنتي انا
عشان هم بيصفوا في شريف بعثه بنات فبقت
سهيله ومعاها اربع بنات من البيت
اللي كبروا كلمه ثلاث لغات عربي الماني
انجليزي معلومات عامه لا يضافيها فيهم حتى
اتجوزوا خلف
هل تفتكروا البنات دول هيربوا عيالهم بنفس
الطريقه اللي اي بدويه هتربي بها عيالها
كده
وتطورت ولسه برده محافظه على مكان طبيعي
مميز تراث سكان محليين بيقدم ثقافه
المجتمع البدوي
والمستثمر اللي هو في الحاله دي شريف
في امثله اخرى
النوبه
اسوان موجوده
فوق حاجه اسمها خزان اسوان
اسوان وده نهايه مدينه اسوان ده السد
العالي احنا عندنا سدين في اسوان خزان
اسوان القديم والسد العالي الجديده ما بين
خزان اسوان والسد العالي عاده ما كانش فيه
سياحه بتروح هناك غير عشان يزوره
في هناك ثلاث جزر كان فيها سكان اصليين
اللي هم سكان الاصليين بتوع المنطقه
لما رحنا زرنا النوبيين لقينا عندهم شواطئ
على النيل رائعه وما بيستقبلوا السياحه طب
بعد اذنكم احنا بس هنعمل عندكم يعني هنجيب
خيامنا وحاجتنا ونقعد معكم بس انتم
هتاكلونا وتشربونا وتفسحونا وتعملوا كل
حاجه انتم كاهل القريه اللي عايشين في
الجزيره
ووافقوا
وابتدين عملنا رحله وكانت ناجحه جدا
والسكان بقى بتوع الجزيره ابتدوا ايه بقى
يتنافسوا مع بعض عشان يخدمونا
بعد كده جئنا لقينا الدنيا بردت جدا في
شهر طوبه اللي هو بيبقى في يناير فالسكان
بتوع الجزيره
لهم في الشارع
التجربه رائعه عمرنا ما رجعنا كم تاني
دلوقتي بقينا بنقعد في البيوت مع الاهالي
هو اللي هم اللي بياكلونا والست البيت
بتطبخ وهناكل كلنا مع بعض
لدرجه ان الناس بقى من اللي بيروحوا
الجزيره قرروا يعملوا بقى تنميه للمجتمع
المحلي يعملوا محاضرات للطلبه
حاجات منه
فمره واحده الجزيره حست ايه ده انا ما
كنتش اعرف ان في سياحه كده انا كل مفهوم
يعني السياحه فندق
واوتوبيسات تروح يزور الاثار ويرجع ويشتري
من البازار وخلاص انما سيح يقعد عندي في
بيتي وياكل معانا ده جديد عليا بس هم لقوا
الخير
احنا ابتدينا في 2012 ببيت واحد بيتاجر في
جزيره هيصه النهارده في حوالي 37 بيت
للايجار جزيره ثانيه اسمها البيجا كانت
منهاره ما فيهاش حد
دخلنا ابتدينا نعمر فيها بنفس موضوع
السياحه البيئيه بونا من المواد الطبيعيه
بقى في عندنا مكان طبيعي مميز القريه كلها
تم اعاده تاهيلها والنهارده بتستقبل صياح
عند النبيين الى جانب الزرع
عشان كده ان شاء الله اسمه جمعيه السياحه
المستدامه مصر بهدف
مساعده اي حد عايز يدخل المجال بتاع
السياحه البيئيه محتاج اي سبورت محتاج اي
حاجه وعشان نعالج التحديات اللي بتواجه
السياحه البيئيه في مصر عشان احنا شايفين
ان هو ده المستقبل بتاع السياحه في العالم
كله مش في مصر بس
عندنا حاجات هنا في دمياط اكيد ودي مهمه
البحث عن الكنوز المخفيه
شكرا جزيلا